Hi, I'm Bethany, a
designer at Google.
These days, UI designers need
to be thinking about phones,
tablets, laptops, TVs,
smartwatches, and beyond.
It can be daunting.
So for the past few
years, Google designers
have been working on
making cross-platform
and multi-screen design easier.
We wanted to build a design
system that felt at home
on every screen, from
the smallest watch
to the largest TV.
From the beginning,
we also wanted
to help third-party apps
express their functionality
and branding in
a consistent way.
The result is what we
call material design.
The material aesthetic
tackles the timely subjects
of realism and minimalism,
distilling and blending
the best of both.
Surfaces and shadows
provide visual cues
grounded in our
experience of reality.
Meaningful motion gives
context to scene changes
and encourages simple
gesture navigation.
And in material design,
the contents of surfaces
adopt a print-like aesthetic.
Refined typography, geometric
iconography, bold color,
and rich imagery lead to
a simple beautiful look.
But this is just the first step.
We recognize that design
is never finished.
Design systems should be
consistent and coherent,
but not static.
We look forward to seeing how
designers around the world
evolve material design with us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]